Khloe Kardashian sued by her former
assistant who claims he was fired after
taking a leave of absence
it's just all
like weird what's happening according to
the lawsuit obtained by E.T Matthew
manhard started working for the mom of
two in January 2019 but in May 2022 he
alleges he dislocated and fractured his
kneecap which required surgery and
hospitalization he says he notified
Chloe the next day that he was unable to
work and would be taking a leave of
absence but Matthew says when he
returned to work six months later in
November he was fired Matthew also
claims the reality star kept him so busy
with tasks that he wasn't able to take
his legally required breaks and alleges
he wasn't paid overtime on days he
worked 12-hour shifts Matthew was
seeking monetary compensation and claims
the reality star broke California labor
laws a rep for Chloe denies Matthew's
allegations in a statement to ET saying
it's unfortunate that he would take this
route and he was properly classified and
comp compensated for his role the rep
adds that Matthew was on a leave of
absence for an extended period and the
role eventually needed to be replaced we
will not tolerate false accusations and
will prove that this is a frivolous
lawsuit but this isn't the first
accusation Cocos had to fight off this
year you just have to deal with it last
month she shut down claims about her
weight loss after an internet trial
accused her of misusing medicine isn't
that crazy the allegation came after the
good American founder shared her latest
magazine photo shoot on Instagram
showing off her fit bod we all want to
be cute over here okay that's when
someone accused Chloe of using
semi-glutide and anti-diabetic
injectable used for chronic weight
management but Coco slammed the claim
saying let's not discredit my years of
working out I get up five days a week at
6am to train working out is one of my
new obsession how healthy obsessions
Chloe added please stop with your
assumptions I guess New Year still means
mean people that's bizarre to me and you
would think people would be happy
um that I'm staying healthy and fit
lawsuits or online trolls Chloe's never
afraid to fight back
[Music]